d'aussi loin que je me souvienne le
voyage dans le temps et le sujet qui m'a
le plus intrigué et passionné première
théorie que je vous ai partagé sur un
bunker scène game le times travel et
l'intrigué principale de la première
partie du film
nombreux d'entre vous souhaitez que je
revienne sur cette thématique plutôt
floues et mal comprise par certains
c'est ce que nous allons faire dans
cette vidéo néanmoins j'aimerais le
faire en vous amenant une approche
philosophique de la chose et essayer de
vous transmettre cette passion pour le
temps allons chercher les réponses caché
d'avengers endgame avec cette vision
totalement personnelle que je vais vous
proposer
je vous conseille également de bien vous
concentrer et de prendre également un
doliprane car nous parlons d'un sujet
fortement complexe
commençons par résumer ce qui lie à
notre disposition dans ndg et il est
tout à fait compréhensible que vous
soyez perturbée à la suite des
événements d'un game nous sommes
habitués un schéma précis du voyage dans
le temps et marvel a décidé de balayer
tout ce sur quoi nous nous basions
vanneur affirme que tout ce qu'il se
passe dans retour vers le futur où ce
genre de film c'est du bullshit
il est impossible de modifier le cours
de l'histoire par le biais d'une action
dans le passé il faut partir du principe
et l'intégrer pour la compréhension du
film c'est que nous avançons constamment
dans le temps ce qui a été fait ne peut
être défait le passé c'est le passé et
il est impossible de retourner en
arrière
le cheikh avengers le démontre très bien
durant le film il ne souhaite pas
modifier le passé car c'est impossible
mais souhaite modifier le présent et
donc leur futur ils partent dans le
passé pour emprunter les pierres de
différentes époques afin de ramener les
50% d'êtres vivants disparu dans le
présent leur voyage dans le passé n'est
qu'un moyen de posséder les outils pour
modifier leurs véritables époque et ce
dans la bonne temporalité il n'y a aucun
problème là dessus je pense que ceci la
plupart l'ont compris et que ce qui vous
intéresse ce sont les paradoxes et
autres conflits temporel nous allons y
venir et pour ça je dois vous amener une
certaine approche
le temps est quelque chose de tout à
fait fascinant et fait partie des sujets
que l'homme maîtrise le moins il y à une
simple règle à respecter et c'est ce que
fait m game le temps peut s'élargir de
se courber se tordre mais avant sera
toujours j'aimerais justement vous
amener la théorie de la relativité
d'albert einstein qui est le cas le plus
concret que nous connaissons sur terre
le seul voyage dans le temps qui serait
potentiellement possible est celui vers
le futur mais pour un aller simple pas
de retour arrière car comme je la firme
c'est impossible est très loin d'être
dans nos connaissances et encore au
21ème siècle
rien ne peut nous faire affirmé le
contraire aucune solution n'a été
trouvée pour inverser le temps car c'est
impossible mais également voyagé à une
époque antérieure
pourquoi est ce que je vous dis tout ça
vous allez rétorqué tout simplement car
l'humain ne maîtrise pas le temps et
donc ne possède aucune base concrète sur
ce dernier
je pense que vous commencez à voir où je
veux en venir le voyage dans le temps
est une oeuvre de fiction empli de
fantasmes que nous rêvons de découvrir
et ça tombe bien les héros font partie
de la fiction aussi ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que la seule base à peu
près concrètes sur le voyage dans le
temps que nous possédons est la théorie
d'einstein et qui ne concerne que le
voyage vers le futur
endgame a donc gens libres pour nous
proposer leur propres règles et leur
propre vision des choses
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait c'est là que se
trouve l'incompréhension de certains par
rapport aux films marvel instaure de
nouveaux codes que nous n'étions pas
habitués à voir et qui pourtant se
rapproche plus possible du réel ceci
perturbe beaucoup et notamment
concernant les paradoxes temporels a
enfin nous y voilà
les paradoxes temporels dans ngame
banner et l'ancien explicite très
clairement que pour éviter de créer de
nouvelles branches et ainsi rester dans
la même réalité
les pierres doivent retourner à leur
place soit c'est respecter dans ndg et
les pierres sont retournés à leur époque
d'origine et il n'y aura donc aucune
perturbation en termes de branche
néanmoins pour ce faire
et ramener tout le monde à la vie les
avengers ont dû effectuer certaines
actions et pas tout le temps prévu voire
pire encore alors erreur scénaristique
choix justifié pour cela j'aimerais vous
parler du rat qui ramena antoine dans
endgame oui oui celui que vous
considérez comme le véritable héros de
ngame mérite son titre car c'est
totalement vrai est ce un choix juste
komikku dû au hasard que sera passée par
là à ce moment précis et marcha sur le
bouton permettant de réactiver le champ
quantique
je pense que non pourquoi cela
connaissez-vous le principe de l'effet
papillon un simple battement d'aile d'un
petit papillon peut provoquer une
gigantesque tornade leur adam and games
en est la parfaite symbolique
un acte que nous pensons minime voire
insignifiant peut avoir des
répercussions énormes sur le futur et la
suite des événements et c'est là l'idée
le rat est un élément perturbateur et de
résolution du film pourquoi
cinématographiquement avoir fait le
choix qu'un rat ramène ans toman du
chant quantique et qui donc
grâce à cette action amènera la
résolution du conflit contre thanos et
bien pour souligner l'idée de l'effet
papillon
j'en suis presque certain le rat est le
premier à avoir fait une action minimes
avec deux conséquences énormes pour en
revenir au paradoxe je pense que vous
comprenez l'idée bien que nos chers
avengers est respecté les conditions que
l'ancien leur avait communiqué et éviter
un énorme problème temporel ces derniers
et pour amener la victoire ont fait
énormément d'action plus ou moins
prémédité ou non contrôlée amnon
plusieurs exemples et il y en a un
paquet mais surtout n'oubliez jamais les
règles fondamentales imposée par rennes
game on avance constamment dans le temps
et le passé n'est pas modifiable
bref parlons de l'eau qui je sais que
vous voulez que je parle depuis
normalement l'eau qui perd contre les
avengers dans leur premier opus et se
fait arrêter puis emmené sur asgard dans
thor 2 dark world mai
dans cette même réalité mais à une
époque différente
tony et athmane ont fait une gaffe et
l'eau qui a donc récupéré le tesseract
et s'est échappé avec effectivement cela
n'impactera pas leur réalité et le
présent des avengers
cependant le fait que l'eau qui
s'échappe avec le tesseract modifie le
cours de l'histoire
lorsque les avengers ont dans le passé
donc une autre histoire secret à cause
de cette petite erreur de calcul
effet papillon numéro un dans la logique
une nouvelle branche de l'histoire se
crée au look y ayant récupéré le
tesseract retournerai auprès de thanos
et lui ramènerait donc la pierre
techniquement exemple numéro deux la
mort de nebula nebula du présent en
tuant l'année bull a dû passer modifie
également le cours de l'histoire
avec cette nouvelle branche qui se fera
donc sans la nebula du passé ouais je
sais c'est complexe et ça fait beaucoup
de nebula bref effet papillon numéro 2
mais en tout cas nous pouvons aller très
loin comme ça rien que la mort de thanos
qui a voyagé dans le temps étant donné
que c'était le thanos d'une autre époque
une branche secret ou thanos n'a jamais
eu les pierres et où les 50% d'êtres
vivants de l'univers ont disparu allez
un petit dernier les avengers ont enlevé
lé enveloppes des pierres du passé bien
avant que cela doit arriver ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que pour
effectuer le snap ultime dans le présent
les avengers ont dû extirper les pierres
de leurs artefacts lapierre de l'esprit
par exemple était dans le centre de laup
qui après le snap
elle ne l'est plus donc une nouvelle
branche va se créer car la découverte de
la pierre dans le sceptre ne se fera pas
avant l'arrivée du tronc et la création
de vision pareil pour le tc raked dans
les années 1970 la destruction du
tesseract pour obtenir la pierre de
l'espace se fera dans infinity ward par
le biais de thanos mais vu que l'
enveloppe de lapierre a été détruite et
retourner dans les années 1970 cela va
créer une nouvelle branche également et
même une branche ou captain marvel
n'existerait pas du coup je vous
laisserai réfléchir à pourquoi
bref essayons d'être le plus concret
possible car je sens que je commence à
vous perdre
le biais de tout ce que je vous raconte
depuis le début il est certain que
marvel a tout prévu comme je vous la
firme le vrai argent temps est une
oeuvre de fiction avant tout et le
principe de l'effet papillon et souligné
dès le début du film grâce aux rats qui
ré actionna la machine du chant
quantique
ce que je peux vous promettre c'est que
ça va créer du très lourd
allons encore plus loin dans la logique
je suis peut-être un peu flou quand je
vous parle de nouvelles branches créé
par le biais des actions des avengers
dans le passé rectifions ça le plus
simplement possible
les avengers son parti dans cinq époques
différentes durant le déroulement d'un
game en 2012 avec tony steve banner et
scott pour récupérer la pierre de
l'esprit est celle du temps en 1970 avec
une nouvelle fois tony et steve où ils
récupéreront la pierre de l'espace du
alors fail en 2012 en 2014 avec barton
natacha au war machine et nebula afin de
récupérer la pierre du pouvoir et celle
de l'âme et enfin en 2013 avec thor et
roquettes ou ces derniers récupéreront
la pierre de la réalité
je garde la cinquième époque pour la fin
de la vidéo ces quatre époques sont les
quatre nouvelles branches créé par noah
bunker ce dû à leur action minime dans
le passé mais qui changeront le cours de
l'histoire
ce n'est pas une action qui permet la
création d'une nouvelle branche mais
l'ensemble de ces dernières effectuée à
un moment précis c'est très important à
comprendre
en 2012 le cours de l'histoire va se
modifier et créer une autre temporalité
soit une autre réalité à cause du voyage
des avengers est ce qu'ils ont fait là
bas tout comme 1970 2014 2013 et enfin
1945 il est temps d'amener la plus
grosse incompréhension d'un game pour
finir en beauté cette vidéo le retour de
captain america en 1945
steve rogers en ramenant les pierres à
leurs époques respectives comme
conseillé par l'ancien décide d'en
profiter pour retourner en 1945 et vivre
la vie qu'il a toujours rêvé d'avoir
avec peggy nous le retrouvons très âgées
en 2023 où ce dernier à environ 115 ans
en 19 ans à peu près sans compter la
période où il était congelé steve en
retournant dans le passé pour vivre sa
vie avec péguy à créer une nouvelle
branche dans l'histoire une branche où
il a pu se marier passé sa vie avec
peggy est également une branche où il y
a deux steve rogers néanmoins la
compréhension n'est pas sur ce qu'il a
pu faire le mal est déjà fait mais sur
pourquoi nous le retrouvons envieux en
2023 lors des événements deng et si nous
le retrouvons vieux à ce moment précis
cela signifie normalement qu'il est
resté dans la même réalité et a souhaité
faire réapparition après que son lui du
passé ramène les pierres dures comme une
boucle en gros mais dans la logique
c'est quelque chose de tout bonnement
impossible les frères russo ont affirmé
que steve a bel et bien créé nouvelle
réalité pour ne rien vous cacher mais
n'ont pas répondu quand à comment il est
revenu dans cette réalité nous pensons
forcément au bracelet créé par tony
néanmoins captain serait a réapparu par
le biais de la machine à voyager dans le
temps
or nous le retrouvons assis sur un banc
plus loin il est donc revenu par le
biais d'un autre moyen
nous ignorons trop de choses sur comment
il a pu revenir car on ne sait pas ce
que la nouvelle réalité qu'il a créée a
pu engendrer
néanmoins steve a ramené avec lui la clé
du voyage dans le temps en 1945 et seuls
les rousseau savent ce qu'il a pu faire
avec
bref il est forcément revenus par le
biais d'un autre moyen je ne peux rien
affirmer de plus malheureusement
pour conclure les frères russo ont été
incroyables et endgame qui est un film
signant la fin d'une très longue épopée
amène de nombreux mystères concernant la
suite il serait très intéressant est
incroyable que nous ayons un film sur
steve rodgers afin de conclure son
histoire sur la réalité qu'il a créé sa
vie avec peggy donc comment il est
revenu à l'époque et la réalité des
avengers celle que nous connaissons sont
nous l'ayons spécialement remarquer les
frères russo ont instauré de lure de
base pour la phase 4 une phase qui se
veut beaucoup plus cosmique est
interdite mentionnait and games vient
d'amener l'arrivée des réalités
alternatives et ce n'est que le début
rien qu'à voir far from je pense que dr
strange sera très utile concernant une
liaison entre les réalités
ainsi quand man avec le chant quantique
et comme je vous l'affirmé en début de
vidéo le voyage dans le temps est une
oeuvre de fiction ou marvel a le droit
d'imposer ses règles
contrairement à harry potter par exemple
la rencontre avec soi même dans une
autre époque n'a pas forcément une
importance temporel et ceci indique
grandement qu'un voyage entre les
réalités ne peut avoir que très peu
d'impact dans marvel
enfin plutôt le mc vous n'imaginez pas
les possibilités infinies que peut
prendre la tournure de la phase 4
je pense qu'on est réellement pas prêt
j'espère en tout cas avoir pu éclairer
votre lanterne
êtes-vous hype et concernant l'arrivée
de la phase 4
je suis sur la préparation de plusieurs
vidéos concernant cette phase justement
dont une en particulier avec l'ami
aéronefs
j'espère que ça va vous plaire
évidemment si cette vidéo vous a plu
vous pouvez vous abonner laisser un
pouce bleus je suis également sur
twitter et/ou type aller bref c'était
argot rock et que le lionheart soit avec
vous
[Musique]